I'm going to be going to a lot of these
when I have a little bit more time these
conferences of the Myositis so it I've
really going in deep and trying to help
everybody yeah that's that's my job now
that's a wonderful thing it really is
you know as we said before it's not life
endings life-changing but there's always
there's always a good site you know
there's always something good of it and
that's the good part about it is helping
people you're always looking for the
good side that's the way you are yes
absolutely I because no matter what
what's happened to me along the road
over the last 45 years or whatever since
I started playing professionally you
know you get knocked down and and I
guess my parents genes it's like don't
give up you know and they say you learn
more from failure than you do from
success that's absolutely true I because
I was a mess when it went crazy you know
and then in 76 because it was just so
much to handle at that time you know and
then but now no it's great